the holidays bring the whole family  together but for those with limited  mobility traveling great distances can  seem impossible is there anything you  can do you'll die alone well now there  is the Acorn stairlift cross-country  system acorn the leader in stair lifts  technology has implemented a chair base  trail system that Criss crosses the  entire continental United States just  have a seat relax and traveled literally  anywhere we covered limited mobility  unlimited  [Music]  [Music]  nothing can keep you away from a warm  and wonderful holiday with your family  you'll never miss a precious holiday  memory again thanks to the Acorn  stairlift cross-country system just sit  there and go anywhere rail system not  yet complete in Wisconsin Missouri  Nebraska Tennessee Georgia West Virginia  Rhode Island Massachusetts New York  Maine and 17 other states pending  ongoing litigation  [Applause]  you